father figures in this talk about father
figures you know was a nice surprise in
this is Terry Bradshaw not that I didn't
know that he's you know he said he can
get out and do some acting video dad
he's he's quite good no he's really good
he just says like one of those people
that just very natural that just
everything he says just you sort of
believe it and and then just a very kind
of lovable you know charismatic guy and
I'm in the movie with Edie helm yeah you
know we both loved working with Terry
and I feel that we were you know a
little bit
we're playing brothers and we're even
sort of offset we were a little
competitive about Terry like I invited
Terry to go get something to eat we're
shooting in Miami was like oh I'm going
with Edie over a Joe stone crabs and I
was like oh we'll meet for a drink later
or something but he's like one of those
you've got a little puppy yeah a little
pizzette a little jealous a little
possessive a little bit but then I just
made it work for my character yeah yeah
are you a good do you guys ever toss the
football around okay good I have a
pretty good arm
you've got arm yeah you're shocked just
you know when the stroke comes I can be
able to do that you know just enjoy
these next three months yeah exactly
once you tell us about the about the
clip you set it up for us I believe okay
yeah let me help you yeah yeah this is
this is my Katya is having a stroke I
think you're sitting on the couch and
you're finding out from your mom who's
played by Glenn Close very good yeah
you're finding out about stuff from your
past Oh about the movie yeah oh I can
set that up I thought I was setting up
the clip yeah yeah okay this is with
sorry what the hell who are you yeah who
the hell is that guy anyone from the
audience can just come out and start
telling us this is not so this is not
the clip that you told me to so you told
me earlier about a clip and then you
switch the clip but never told me is
that right Merry Christmas
listen Owen I don't want you to get the
idea that we're an incompetent show
we're doing the best we can you've been
around that long yeah so the clip we're
about to see is me with my girlfriend
and yeah I mean I think it's you know
you'll see what wait a minute all that
just to get you to this the hell was
that oh you'll see having a conniption
I just I'm assuming the movie as a
mystery movie yeah set up with the world
maybe I did or no no I think it's fine
we're gonna show the clip okay and if
there are any questions we'll take them
afterwards okay no one's ever done that
let's look at this clip from father
figures gotta come over to why when are
you gonna visit yeah kailani come here I
want you to meet someone really special
to me
so what I've been sleeping with
exclusively for the past six months Wow
six whole months
that's what I'm saying it's really
special a little hot Peter I
[Music]
I can feel your brother inside you I am
inside you you want yeah we're twins
that's called a honey that is a sacred
Hawaiian greeting you just got yeah is
that is that all right did I look a
little tired I look at that clip you
look tired